The one piece manga just showed us EXACTLY WHY
the Sun God Nika’s abilities are ABSOLUTELY
BROKEN. Because as we see at the end of this
chapter, Bonney revealed a completely new
power that allowed her to imitate Nika’s
rubber fist, and, man, did it leave this
miserable government agent completely knocked
out. And all of this has got me thinking that
if Bonney’s attack was SO POWERFUL just by
imitating Nika, then Luffy’s Nika abilities
are 100% the most game-changing abilities in
the story. Which of course makes sense for our
main character to have, but let’s break down
what makes them just so ridiculously powerful.
First, there’s the actual rubbery stretchy
abilities that everyone has discussed many
times now, but to see it being used by someone
else is just absolutely mind-blowing. I mean keep
in mind that Bonney was basically just a normal
child. She didn’t have any special lineage or
training that made her extra strong, so the fact
that this partial Nika transformation allowed
her to take out a full-blown government agent
is just incredible. Beyond that though, it is
the versatility of these powers that truly makes
them so strong because Luffy, and now somewhat
for Bonney, can adapt the powers to whatever
they need in order to overcome the battle.
However, there is another part of Nika’s abilities
that just really stood out to me which is the
power of belief. Because we’ve seen all throughout
the story that Luffy, and more recently Nika,
bring hope to those who were about to give up.
You can think back to almost any arc in One Piece
and Luffy is the one who brought hope. But even
bringing this to the current backstory, it was
Kuma’s belief in Nika from a young age that really
helped him never give up his search for freedom
and a cure for Bonney. So it was just incredibly
awesome to see that when Bonney needed to escape
from the person keeping her captive, she thought
of Nika and those powers helped her escape.
Honestly though, it goes even further than
that because at this point I’m starting to
truly believe that Nika was basically a god
that the Buccaneers and even other races used
to worship. If you really look into it,
there are signs pointing to Sun God Nika
being a major religious figure all throughout
the story. If you haven’t seen these examples,
I can just point out the sun-logo that appears in
many places such as the cross in Kuma’s church,
the fishmen sun pirate symbol, the
Kozuki crest, the Alabasta flag,
and even in Skypiea. And the one thing that
ties all these people and places together is
their relationship to the Ancient Kingdom. So
at this point, since we know Nika was a major
figure in the Ancient Kingdom, I’m starting
to think Nika was truly their founder or even
a literal god that many of the Ancient
Kingdom allies started to worship. Which
is how the Buccaneer religion started, and
that has somehow carried on to the very day.
And while we’re talking about religion, it
is also need to bring up that I kinda wonder
if Mihawk was a former Holy Knight who was
eventually converted to the Nika religion.
Which sounds crazy, I know, but there are a ton
of connections between Mihawk and Imu’s throne,
such as the markings on the throne being
very similar to the markings on Mihawk’s
sword. Plus Mihawk’s eyes are eerily similar
to Imu’s. But you might be wondering how all
this makes me think that he believes in
Nika, and the answer to that is mostly
based on his design. Because clearly he has
a whole Christianity vibe going on. In fact,
his cross necklace reminds me a lot of the
cross that Kuma had in his church back in
the Sorbet Kingdom. And if Mihawk does believe
in Nika then it would explain why he let good
pirates like Luffy and Zoro survive when
he so easily could have killed them all.
Now, I just had to bring that up because man it
was just so cool to see Bonney’s Nika power and
this honestly new power might be one of the MOST
BROKEN abilities in the entire story. Seriously,
just by believing in this new future, Bonney
can literally transform her entire body. Which
doesn’t make ANY SENSE! Trust me, I know! So
let’s break down how this power works and the
GAME-CHANGING effects it could have on the end
of the Egghead Island arc. Because this power
is called Distorted Future, and when Bonney uses
it she can transform part or all of her body into
something entirely different than her normal self.
We first saw her use this power in chapter 1072,
when she became this super buff version
of herself. And now that we have a better
understanding of this power, it seems that
Bonney was imagining herself in the future
as a Buccaneer or maybe just some super strong
fighter and this power made it come true. Which
is just a mind-blowing power, but it gets
even crazier in this chapter because when
Bonney was about to be recaptured by the
world government, she remembered that Nika
had a rubbery body which allowed her to somehow
imagine herself as Nika and literally transform
her arm into a giant Gear-3 like punch. I
mean, what??? How is that even possible?
So just to clarify, at this point it seems
that as long as Bonney can imagine herself
becoming something in the future, even
if there is no way that it is possible,
then she can transform herself in the present.
Which when you first think about it,
you might be like “yeah, that’s cool,
but it’s not amazing”,. But if you are
thinking that, STOP. RIGHT NOW! Because
this power could be the key to changing
the entire one piece world. Don’t believe
me? Well, listen to all the ways this single
ability could change the end of Egghead island.
Let’s start off with Bonney herself
because when we last saw her on Egghead,
she was about to be executed by a bunch of marine
gunfire. However, with her distorted future power,
she could simply turn body back into a rubbery
Nika form, just like we saw in this chapter.
Which means that just like Luffy, this new
rubber body should allow Bonney to bounce
back all the bullets. So I know we are all
expecting Kuma to show up and save the day,
but Bonney may not even need him in order to
save herself. And let’s not stop there because
what if Bonney imagined a future where she was
the strongest swordswomen in the world? Could
she then just take one of Zoro’s swords and
start slicing up Saturn like she was Mihawk???
But that’s just the start because next let's
imagine that Bonney can also use this power
on other people. And I mean, why not, since she
can use her normal abilities power to make people
older or younger and even used this power on
Vegapunk to turn him into a baby. So let's assume
she can use Distorted Future on other people.
Well, we know Luffy was exhausted lying on the
ground, but what if Bonney imagines a future where
Luffy is completely healed? Or a future where
Kizaru is an ally instead of an enemy? Or a future
where Saturn was so old that he literally turns
into dust? Surely, there will be some restrictions
on what she can do, but the possibilities are just
SO FUN to think about. And honestly, I think it
would be incredibly powerful if Bonney was the
one who saved herself and everyone else instead
of Kuma. Sure, Kuma has been the tragic hero of
the backstory, but just imagine how great it would
be if Bonney didn’t need his protection anymore
and instead she is the one who is able to save
him. And what better way than to imagine a future
where Kuma never lost his memories, which would
bring her adopted father back to his normal self.
Man… what I would give to see this become reality.
Now, as incredible as that would be, I do
wonder if Bonney has an ever greater level
to unlock with this power. Of course, I’m
talking about awakening. Because something
to keep in mind is that at this time Bonney has
only had her devil fruit for about six years,
which is a relatively short time to master its
powers. So there is a good chance that she hasn’t
awakened her devil fruit yet. And what other
perfect opportunity could there be for her to
actually awaken it than in this high-pressure,
life-or-death situation on Egghead island?
And now, we can’t just say she might awaken it
without speculating what that awakening could be,
so let's look at what we know about Paramecia type
awakenings. Basically, every awakened paramecia we
have seen allows the user to use their devil fruit
powers on the environment. So with this in mind,
plus our current understanding of
Bonney’s Distorted Future ability,
I wonder if awakening Bonney’s fruit could
allow her to imagine a Distorted Future of
the world around her. Like for example, a
future where Egghead Island was even more
technologically advanced than it already is. It
sounds funny, but I’m just imagining some kind
of laser cannons or something all locked onto
Saturn and blasting him to bits. And this idea
isn’t all that ridiculous since the world used to
be even more technologically advanced in the past.
Or if we really want to get crazy, what
if Bonney could affect the entire world
somehow? I’m just picturing her imagining
a world that isn’t oppressed by the world
government. How cool would that be?
Just imagine multiple panels of people
and races all over the world living in
peace instead of poverty and slavery.
Which I’ll admit sounds just too good
to be true, but it’s fun to think about.
In the end though, I’m sure Oda will
have some reasonable restrictions for
this power that keep it from being
too absolutely broken. But still,
since he is emphasizing it here, it simply has
to play a role in the climax of Egghead island.
Speaking of distorted futures, though, Oda
certainly changed MY OPINION on Monkey D.
Dragon because in this chapter we learned that
he was keeping track of Luffy for his ENTIRE
childhood. That’s right everyone, Dragon isn’t
a completely deadbeat father. Seriously though,
it seems that every time the Revolutionaries would
visit the Goa kingdom, Dragon would stop by to
check on his son. Although he likely kept himself
hidden from everyone. And if I had to guess, this
is most likely because he was trying to protect
Luffy and the villagers from becoming a target
of the world government. That or Dragon didn’t
want Luffy to be captured and used against him,
but either way, it seems Dragon actually
cared more about Luffy than we all thought.
By the way, can we all just appreciate
Dragon’s stone-cold confidence when
he tells Kuma that he better stop talking
about Luffy unless he wants to die? I mean,
wow! We’ve all seen just how powerful Kuma
is during this flashback, so for Dragon to
just casually threaten Kuma like that just shows
that Dragon isn’t messing around when it comes
to his son. But this dynamic between these two
father figures is also incredibly interesting.
I wonder if Dragon’s situation is at all like
Kuma’s where he lost the person he loves to
the world government. That line about “a child
is a parents’ weakness” just makes me wonder
if Luffy’s mother somehow sacrificed herself to
the world government in order to protect Luffy,
and that is why Dragon eventually left the
Marines and started the Revolutionaries.
Bringing this back to Kuma though, this chapter
clearly confirmed that Kuma knew who Luffy was
and was also probably looking out for
him once he became a pirate. Certainly,
their meeting at Thriller Bark wasn’t the
first time Kuma had seen Luffy. Which just
makes me question even more if Kuma would
have ever gone through with his orders
to kill Luffy in the first place. At this
point, I highly doubt it because it seems
like Oda has had Kuma and Dragon’s
relationship figured out all along.
But one thing that still confuses me is why
didn’t Kuma go meet with Bonney once she was
free and a pirate. I mean sure, he promised
the Gorosei that he would never see her again,
but there was definitely time for him to meet with
her and then escape the world government together.
Just think about it. Kuma didn’t have his
memories completely erased until after Marineford,
and at that time Bonney had been a pirate for a
few years already. I guess you could say that the
government had already erased those parts of
Kuma's memories, which makes a little sense,
but on the other hand, in this very chapter,
he was shown still helping the revolutionaries.
Plus he’s always used his famous “Where
would you like to go on vacation” phrase,
so there’s got to be some memory of Bonney still
in there somewhere. And maybe you could say that
he was worried Bonney would become a slave again,
but come on. Kuma is easily one of the strongest
Warlords and it would probably take at least one
or more admirals to take him out, so I definitely
think he could have used his powers to find
Bonney and escape the world government together.
Who knows, maybe we’ll find out more about that
soon, but no one can say that Kuma abandoned
Bonney because at least he was trying to write
her letters. However, as we saw in this chapter,
those letters were being destroyed by the
government agents watching over Bonney.
Which just adds to the tragedy that all this time
Bonney didn’t hear from her adopted father. And if
you think about it, Bonney has not heard from
Kuma since he left her back in Sorbet kingdom
around two and a half or three years ago. However,
there might be some hope for Bonney to read those
letters because if you look back at the first time
we saw Kuma send someone away using his powers,
he does look down into his Bible before sending
this ghost girl away. To me this means that Kuma
was using the Bible to keep all of his notes
about the places wanted to visit with Bonney,
so I can just imagine that even if Kuma
shows up in Egghead and ends up sacrificing
himself to save everyone, then Bonney will
probably still be able to read the book he
leaves behind and maybe visit the places
herself in memory of her adopted father.
Now let's swing back around to the end of this
chapter because Bonney’s escape also gave us a
hint about one interesting theory about the
Gorosei and Imu. Because during Bonney’s
plan to escape the government agents, we find out
that those agents don’t actually know that Bonney
has devil fruit powers. And if we assume that
the agents don’t know about her powers then it
also makes sense that the rest of the government
wouldn’t know about them either. I mean, how dumb
would that be if Saturn or someone else knew but
didn’t tell the people watching over Bonney. But
let’s assume that they didn’t know at all, which
means that the government certainly wasn’t using
Bonney’s powers for themselves. And to give
a bit more context on why this is important,
we have long wondered how the Gorosei and Imu
seem to be virtually immortal. We’ve thought
it might be the Immortality Surgery, but another
strong option was Bonney’s age related devil fruit
abilities. Clearly though if the government
didn’t know Bonney had these powers then
they wouldn’t have been using her to keep them
young, so that just crosses one potential option
off the list for explaining how the Gorosei
and Imu appear to have lived for so long.
And that’s just one of many super interesting
little details in this chapter because during
one of Kuma’s many visits back to Egghead island,
he also met Stussy, who is Vegapunk’s clone of
Miss Buckingham. What’s most interesting about
this meeting is that Stussy is a clone who was
basically given humanity while Kuma is becoming a
cyborg while losing his humanity. Stussy even goes
as far to compare their situations and ask which
one is more tragic. But while this is interesting
to think about by itself, I want to bring this
back to the situation at Egghead island where
we have a ton of interesting comparisons. First,
there is obviously the Seraphim, who like Stussy,
are actually clones. However, unlike Stussy, they
do not seem to have the same kind of freedom that
she does. So this is just another reminder
that the Seraphim are going to have a super
important role to play in the future, and don’t
be surprised if they eventually gain their own
type of freedom where they can act of their own
will instead of being forced to follow orders.
But that’s not all because we also have another
human who is virtually a slave with admiral
Kizaru. And since he has basically given himself
up to just following orders, I really do wonder
if he will have a change of heart and rebel
against the orders of the world government.
Maybe Kuma showing up will inspire him or
something that Bonney does will change him,
but I just can’t help but see the similarities
between Kizaru’s situation and what Stussy said
in this chapter, and hopefully it will lead to
the end of the World Government’s rule very soon.
Now we already talked about this new information
that Dragon actually kept an eye on Luffy during
his childhood, and things have worked out
pretty well for Luffy with the way things
were. But man it must have been hard for
Dragon to keep himself from going down and
talking to his son. I mean can you just
imagine if you were a parent but had to
stay away from your children? Seriously, talk
about torture, but have you ever wondered what
would happen if Dragon didn’t stay away? In
other words, what would happen if Luffy was
raised by Dragon? And if you want to check
out that video, you can click right here.
Shanks for watching, and
I’ll see you in the next one.